vous êtes d'argenteuil et vous avez subi
un jour un contrôle d'identité qui a
très mal tourné est ce que vous pouvez
nous dire ce qui s'est passé exactement
après que les policiers aient tenté de
contrôler votre identité
alors bonjour bonsoir à tous je sortais
du travail ce soir là et ce qui s'est
passé c'est que j'allais en direction de
mon véhicule pour rentrer dormir c'était
assez tard j'avais fini à 4 heures du
matin et il ya ces policiers qui sont
arrivés et qui déjà sont descendus s'est
brusquement de leur véhicule et qui sont
arrivés vers moi mais comme s'il était
déjà énervé quoi et on m'a attrapée et
directement me contre le mur a juste
demandé ce qui se passait je leur
demandais pour l'anglais par les envois
d'e on voit des images qui illustrent le
propos est exactement
voilà et on m'a dit que c'était un
contrôle de police
pas de souci j'ai obtempéré mais on m'a
forcé mais j'ai quand même obtenu est
chose normale et j'avais mes demandes
contre le mur et deux policiers qui à
droite à un beau chien qui me palper et
on a ce dernier policier qui a fouillé
les poches de mon ami qui s'est avancé
vers moi qui a écarté deux policiers et
qui m'a mis un coup au niveau de la
tempe gauche gratuitement et à partir de
ce moment là ça a été un achat j'ai pris
énormément de coups on m'a emmené de
plus en plus vers le fond de la ruelle
il s'était beaucoup plus sombre est
vraiment c'était beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de coups au sol on m'a
étranglée parce qu'on a on m'a projeté
au mas jeté au sol
on va étrangler il ya donc un moment
vous n'aviez résiste et refuse également
libéré tenu des propos aucun aucun je
leur disais mais pourquoi vous faites ça
pour que fait ça lâchez-moi arrêté et
non il continué il continuer continuer
comme j'ai dit au sol il ya un policier
qui m'est rendu
un policier qui m'appuient avec son
genou sur la cage thoracique et à
policer kim écrase la cheville qui est
debout et
pendant des longues minutes cc je
n'arrivais plus à respirer j'étais je
peux franchement je ne sais plus ce qui
se passait je pensais que c'était la fin
quoi pour moi c'était fini tout ce que
je leur disais voulait pas et voulait
pas m'écouter enfin je leur disais
d'arrêter fin des des fois même si je
tendais même en fait si vous voulez me
menotter
faites vite mais qu'on arrête le ce
calvaire quoi et non ils s'arrêtaient
pas il s'arrêtait pas ils s'arrêtaient
pas et un moment donné ce soir étaient
ils m'ont ils m'ont relevé ils m'ont
emmené aux véhicules de police pareil
ils m'ont emmené j'étais à droite à
gauche il me tenait en aucun cas j'ai
porté une résistance ou quoi que ce soit
et ils m'ont emmené au commissariat de
la au commissariat ce qui s'est passé
c'est que l'on m'a laissé dans une dans
une salle où je vomissais j'ai été
menottée en même temps j'ai perdu
connaissance quelques secondes à ce
moment là vous savez ce qu'ils ont fait
nîmes ont apporté une poubelle une
poubelle pour vomir dans la poubelle une
petite poubelle en plastique
voilà après mon ego placé en garde à vue
ils ont il mourut ils ont ils m'ont
refusé de voir un médecin
donc j'ai pas vu de médecin excusez-moi
j'ai vu un médecin deux fois mais deux
de la police et il m'a donné enfin il
m'a donné des somnifères que je n'ai pas
pris parce que ça n'avait rien à voir et
même au commissariat je leur expliquais
que j'avais rien fait cherté du boulot
je voulais rentrer dormir tout
simplement
c'est mon véhicule qui est juste là le
blanc et le restaurant est juste à côté
et quand vous avez dit il ya quelques
instants j'ai cru que c'était fini vous
avez eu peur pour votre vie pour moi
c'est j'allais mourir pour moi c'était
fini je ne je ne respirait plus je
n'arrivais plus à leur dire arrêtez
c'est ccc je voyais plus rien j'avais un
coup dc1 un genou rien rien et
commissaire a en fait ils ont aussi
menti à mon avocate en lui disant que je
ne voulais pas d'avocate or que c'est
faux dès le départ j'ai dit que j'avais
ma propre avocate et ils lui ont dit que
j'avais pas besoin d'elle ce qui s'est
passé c'est que moi de mon côté il ya
mon ami qui a visé mes parents tout le
monde bref l'avocate et c est l eau
radicale elle est quand même se déplacer
ce qu'ils ont voulu faire en fait
c'était me faire passer la confrontation
seul avec sauf que l'avocate elle et
elle a donc finalement ils l'ont dit
c'est bon vous êtes là bas on fait la
confrontation quoi et même pas dans la
confrontation en fait ce qui m'a ce qui
m'a déplu c'est que les les op j enfin
le pj qui était sur place a tenté de
modifier des dépositions de policiers
donc quand un policier dit qu'il m'a
porté aucun coup au bout d'un moment il
dit si on lui avait mis des vrais coups
et que lopez yves modifié avec mon
avocate justement grâce à ça qu'elle
soit là elle lui dit non tu laisses adam
le dans le pv et tu rajoutes si tu as
envie
donc de là ce qui s'est passé c'est que
les policiers ont fait de fausses
écritures
donc ce qui s'est passé c'est tout ce
qu'ils ont dit dans leurs dépositions et
dans leur plainte parce qu'ils ont aussi
déposé plainte contre moi étaient faux
fausse oui là c'est complètement et donc
aussi lourd là ce qu'ils disent dans les
pv c'est que je suis contre le mur je me
retourne et que je les frappe
ce qu'ils disent dans leur pv c'est
qu'en allant aux véhicules de police
j'essaye de me sauver
tout est faux tout tout tout tout tout
et quels ont été les suit alors pensé
pour ses policiers
aucune suite pour sa part compte grâce à
la vidéo et grâce à mon avocate qui a
réussi à la verser au dossier
moi j'ai été relaxé auprès du tribunal
j'ai aussi déposé plainte auprès des
gipn qui bon je suis un petit peu déçu
non pas poursuivi les policiers mais ont
constaté les faits donc
j'ai un document qui a testé de l'igpn
au tribunal donc une preuve en plus pour
moi que j'avais bien reçu tel et un tel
coup hasna ces moments là donc toutes
mes déclarations étaient vraies et
correspondait à la vidéo et ben voilà et
grâce à ça aujourd'hui j'ai été relaxé
par la justice
je peux juste posé une vraie bien sûr
les agents et yacine aujourd'hui alors
je pourrais te paraît totalement
transparents sont originaires de la même
ville que yacine que je connais bien il
est connu dans la ville pour être un
acteur associatif qui continue toujours
de s'impliquer auprès des plus jeunes et
des sans abri et je pense que c'est
important que tu dises à tout le monde
ce que tu dis aujourd'hui aux jeunes que
tu rencontres d'aujourd'hui contre la
police qu'est ce que tu dis aux gamins
que tu croises et qui te parle de ton
histoire c'est important que tout le
monde entend en fait je leur dis qu'il
faut pas avoir de haine envers la police
moi même je ne suis pas anti flics je ne
suis pas anti flics mais aujourd'hui
malheureusement j'ai peur de la police
j'ai peur de me faire contrôler j'ai
peur quoi quand j'étais plus jeune pour
moi la police en fait c'était vraiment
les des personnes qui étaient là pour me
protéger si j'avais un souci c'était eux
qui allaient qui allait venir quoi
maintenant j'ai eu gilles d'accord je
vais pas me faire contrôler je respecte
je me fais contrôler ça m'arrivait de me
faire contrôler récemment et je me suis
rendu compte que j'avais peur de rester
de doha un policier c'est fou quand même
c'est que je retournais ma tête j'avais
peur mais j'ai obtempéré et tout s'est
bien passé relatant et sam et y arriver
aussi de me de montreux tenir justement
sur une action que j'ai menée avec mon
association dont je suis le président
qui récoltent 95 j'ai pu parler avec des
policiers qui encore une fois sont
revenus sur le même sur le discours que
madame c'est qu'il ya des excusez moi du
terme il ya des connards partout mais
mais voilà c'est des choses qui ne
devraient pas arriver qu'ils ne
devraient vraiment pas arriver et donc
pour répondre à ta question je précise
par la haine je dis pas aux jeunes de
aller frapper la police au contraire je
leur dis de respecter et et moi même je
les respecte au jour d'aujourd'hui
malgré ce qui m'est arrivé ce que vous
allez raconter gravissime et on reçoit
le message d'apaisement que vous faites
passer